When I was a child my brother would tell me a bedtime story about the man who murdered our Father
But all the things we would do to that man
He never should have trusted Sasi you never should have either
dad
Thought many faces and look forward to seeing this one
Don't we have?
Before the Sun comes up tomorrow I
Wasn't a king, but you were
The fact that John's real parents were who John's real parents were is not news to us at this point?
What we don't know is the way that John is going to take this
How's the explosion gonna look Sam as a brother of the Nights Watch and John or more brothers than Brandon John never really were
he knows it's gonna hurt John and it's going to
shatter his whole worldview for all they know the army of the Dead could attack the next day and
Someone has to tell John before that
He's being told something that he both knows is true and can't handle
So he tries to throw
things in front of it to prevent him from having to deal with the
Truth of what he's being told the thing he throws in front of it here is the fact that it means his father
Was lying to him his whole life. You've never been in a busted you are truly actually
I'm thrown the truth that Samwell tells John is probably the most incendiary fact in the entire
World of the show we chose to play the whole thing on
John's face because as great a job as John Bradley is doing presenting this information. He's really just presenting information. We know already
Daenerys is how quick she shouldn't be?
Strewth it's the truth
Hi everyone, its charlie we got our brand-new Game of Thrones season 8 episode 2 trailer to break down
There's a whole bunch of new scenes. Obviously. They're still getting ready for the big battle
So if you're brand new to the channel, I'm doing Game of Thrones videos all season long
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos. We're doing that HBO now giveaway
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
And leave a comment on the video obviously careful for spoilers from episode 1 if you haven't seen it yet
But we see Jaime facing the Alliance Council in Daenerys to answer for one not only showing up without the Lannister army that he promised
But also answering for his past misdeeds
They're sort of taking him to task for all the terrible things that he's done because right now he's basically surrounded with all the people
Who have been his worst enemies since season 1 of the TV show?
So now he's sort of trying to make good on his promises. I'm trying to do a good thing
So he has to explain that to him. You see him panicking as the scene goes on just looking all over the place
Looking at brands still freaked out from when he arrived
That was one of my favorite reunions during episode 1 so he arrives and they have this mere moment from season 1 episode 1 where?
He pulls his helmet off and you know shakes his golden locks
But this time he pulls his hood off and runs his hands through his hair again
But he's got so many more city miles on him
Look at how much older he looks from the pilot episode
Then bran just gives him that creepy calm stare as if he's piercing his soul with his eyes
Usually when bran stares at someone during an episode it implies that something bad is about to happen
like when he stirred it to nearest I wondered what it was that he was peering into the future because remember he has
greensight
So he does have limited
visions of the future and he can see their past pretty easily as well is a little bit better at seeing the past than he
Is at seeing the future because the future can change
But like we're all thinking about visions Daenerys visions the house the undying we'll see how much things can change and how much of its
Predetermined but I love Daenerys his speech there apparently
Viserys told her all kinds of stories about the Kingslayer the man who murdered our Father even though the Mad King
Deserved to die and was one of the most terrible people in history
It's a little bit weird that Daenerys is upset that he was killed
I think she's more upset about having to live in exile and being away from her home her entire life
Not so much that she loved her father
Like I think she understands what a tear a person he was but I think just in general
This is Jamie having to answer for all of his past misdeeds. Now. You look at Sansa
She's just kind of giving me a cold stare
I don't think that she had any really bad encounters with him in King's Landing while she was trapped by the Lannisters
I think it's more by association because she probably knows what was going on between Jaime and Cersei at least by this point
Even if she didn't know it at the time if there's any Lannisters that she has a grudge against though. It would be Cersei
She's the one that she's mostly focused on because she used to idealize Cersei
she wanted to be the queen but now she knows the truth of things remember back during season one - she was so smitten with
Jaime because he was quote-unquote Prince Charming
But then obviously the big twist by the end of the episode is that he's sleeping with his sister and he tried to kill bran
Nikolaj coster-waldau actually said something funny in the behind the scenes for the episode where he's like if bran
Tells everyone what I did then I'm absolutely screwed. You notice bran giving him the cold stare in the room here
Obviously brand doesn't hold a grudge anymore just because he sort of left behind a lot of that
I think he remembers his human life
But like when Jon Snow said you're a man now and he basically tells him not quite like I'm not quite human anymore
Jon's kind of shaken by it
It's just a way to remind you that he sort of left those things behind which is why he stops them in that moment says
We don't have time for this the army of the Dead is coming
They have a dragon you see Tyrion over on the side here with a worried look on his face
Please don't feed my brother to the dragons then
there's the scene with Daenerys and Sansa dealing with the aftermath of that and what they're gonna do now that they know this Cersei isn't
Sending any help when they sort of shade each other for trusting things that Cersei says I'm not sure why
Daenerys is mad at Sansa because Santa's big thing during episode one was taking Tyrion to task for believing Cersei
So it's not clear if there's something that Cersei said that Sansa
believed maybe she's talking about things that happened earlier on the show during season 1 season 2
Everyone's in their new outfits except for Tyrion Jorah and Varys Sansa has their special new leather armor on it's a huge upgrade and Daenerys
Has her new red fur dress we get the Arya voiceover from the original trailer death has many faces
I look forward to meeting this one talking about the night King and the White Walkers holding up that dragonglass dagger
You see Gendry forging more dragonglass weapons the stark soldiers
The Dothraki bloodrider is the Knights of the Vale the unsullied all making their prepper
It seems like they're testing this balista or trebuchet in the daylight
Just getting ready because it's before the actual battle because the battle itself doesn't seem like it starts until nightfall just based on the previous
Trailer footage we've seen like when the White Walkers horse walks up into frame. It's fully Knight by that point
You see that Samwell has already given surge aura hearts Bane
I wonder what that conversation is gonna be like sorry about yesterday and telling you about your parents
Sorry, my queen Daenerys burned them alive
Can I borrow that Valyrian sword by the way, if you're not gonna be using it during this big battle?
We haven't really had any moments between the little bear and surgery yet
Because remember there's all that he fled Ned Stark's justice because he was slaving his people so the North remembers the little bear is sort
Of like team Mean Girls this season, sir
Jorah is on my death predictions list, but if he were to survive
It'd be interesting to see if he just continues trying to serve Daenerys or if he would ever want to go home
But because he's so devoted to her
I think that as long as he's living and breathing he'll just continue to stay by her side and surfer in whatever way he can
There's a shot of Daenerys entering the crypts of Winterfell to go talk to John Snow
Obviously, he's still shook by the news of his true parentage
I do think that Daenerys learns the truth during this episode at some point
He probably tells her it'll probably cause all kinds of problems for their relationship
And make things within the Alliance that much more tense before the big battle
But then there's a shot of Arya testing out the dragonglass arrows
I think it's a nice callback to the pilot episode when she was showing a brain and the other stark children in the yard just
Being a really amazing shot
Jon Snow talking to torment before nightfall who's just arrived with the rest of his band of wildlings and probably the Nights Watch as well
Telling them all about the night King's abstract art installation the fact that they're coming
There were a lot of people that were curious about what exactly that message means what the symbol means because it keeps recurring the night
King has been making it since season 1 of this show
So I'll probably do a separate video about that later this week then Jon Snow
this seems like ed in the middle and Samwell on top of the ball because they were all members of the Nights Watch and they
Stood atop of the wall back during season 1 so it's a nice callback to them being brothers of the Nights Watch
They're literally watching the night move in as in the night king
So just a lot of visual metaphors and callbacks to season 1 of the show
like we saw a during episode 1
Sir Jorah riding into formation on his horse with hearts bein attached to his hip
Gray worms saying goodbye to miss and I gray worm is also on my death predictions list
But the actor who plays him said that he would have a very unsettling storyline
So I'm wondering if he's one of the characters that they raised as a white like one of the good characters that we've been following
This whole time that then turns around and becomes this undead zombie coming for the other heroes
There will be another great horror moment
like the one that we got with little Lord umber at the end of episode 1 so everybody let me know in the comments which
Other main characters you think are gonna come back as whites during one of these big battles
But then there's a shot of Daenerys with a really sad and worried look on her face
Maybe this is her either being worried about the big battle that's coming up
Or maybe she's already found out about Jon Snow being a secret Targaryen
There's so many upsetting things that she could learn that would cause her to make this face
But then you see Jon Snow in the yard and his new outfit preparing for battle then Tyrion at night before the battle starts peeking
His head over the walls, which is a nice mirror for his scenes during Blackwater back during season two too bad this time
They don't have a crap-ton of wildfire to unleash on the night king's army the really interesting thing
I think we all need to pay attention to in this episode is Tyrians storyline as well, because what happened during Blackwater?
He saved the city with his wildfire plan, but then didn't get any credit for it
So because everybody has been hating on him and he's been making so many bad decisions
What might wind up happening is is that he has a great idea for defending Winterfell?
But because he looks like such a fool Cersei not bringing her reinforcements and him just doubling down on that so much
Maybe they don't listen to him and something terrible
happens and it just winds up leading him down this darker path this season because we're sort of seeing the
Downfall of Tyrion like he used to be super clever
He was amazing the first couple of seasons super witty the last couple of seasons
He's just been making one bad call after another. So this just seems like it's gonna be the next step in that descent
So pay special attention to what's going on with Tyrion during the episode
But then there's that scene of Jon Snow and Samwell talking about treason Daenerys. Jon Snow's true parentage
It all gets tied up in the idea of fixing the realm after they're all done
Remember how Tyrion Varys in Davos were talking about the solution?
Well, the best thing to do would just be to get the two of them married
the only thing that's
Complicating that right now is that John is a secret Targaryen and getting over the fact that she's really his aunt
Is he comfortable with that? How are they gonna handle that going forward?
I think the main idea here is that they love each other
So eventually they'll move past it. And yes
They will eventually get married at some point either during the season or in the future of the show if they don't do some giant
jump forward in time but short term is just meant to cause a bunch of drama and chaos within the Alliance because
Remember, they took him to task for bending the knee. We named you king in the north. You're supposed to be our king
So if the North found out that he were the true heir to the Iron Throne
They would probably be even more upset with Daenerys for trying to assert her claim
So it's all just meant to complicate things as we head into this giant huge battle
Let me know in the comments what you guys are most excited about for episode 2
What will happen is is I will do a Q&A video tomorrow
So leave any questions in the comments that you want me to include in that and there'll be some more bonus videos later this week
Congratulations to the giveaway winner from my last big video, Brian Brown
Please email me on the about page of my channel so I can get your details
Click here for my Game of Thrones season 8 episode 1 video and click here for my Game of Thrones Season 8 death predictions
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay awesome, I'll see you guys tonight